we've known each other for a number of
years uh
when you uh i think years ago you
took me to a korean spa we were naked
together yes
yes um and uh i was so excited when your
nomination came out that i
texted you and said i can't believe
that i've been naked with an academy
award nominee
so has that ever that's never happened
before three other times okay
but you can't believe this one this one
i can't believe the others we had we
were in a relationship
and so oh it made a lot of sense and
it's documented
it's documented thank you no thank you i
was
thanks for that message that was really
kind um
i don't know i'm i'm still processing
all of that
because we're still in pandemic
yeah right yeah are we done no we're not
done okay we're not done you know that's
the crazy thing
is that uh i think we're in this
maddening time right now where many
people
are half vaccinated or some are fully
vaccinated
some are soon to be vaccinated but we're
not there yet
and we don't even know when that's going
to happen i know
you've been i mean tell me about your
year in in
quarantine what's that been like well
first i mean like i'm one of the lucky
ones uh
we we have a house uh i have a family
and
um you know it was all beautiful and
you have all those nice things um but
you know what was crazy about the
pandemic is like
the battlefield is like yourself
and oh my god you know what i mean yes i
do you got to find out about
who you are yes during that time and
uh there's a lot of stuff to clean up in
there yeah
yeah are you talking to me or about
yourself because
i'm talking oh my god okay because you
were saying it and i was thinking day
two
of this pandemic yeah i got a good hard
look at myself and i did not like what i
saw right
because everybody was in like panic
flight or flight so it's like what did
you choose
like and i've and i've kind of simulated
that on walking dead like what
weapons do you choose or like people do
you hang out with or like
that's vehicles i didn't even occur to
me you spent seven years
on this show that was all about
surviving
this crazy virus uh and
you should have the requisite skills
which is immediately get to the woods
somewhere in georgia
i thought none of those things you know
what i mean like i just i i
i exposed myself because i was like what
do i do all i did was like we're all
gonna die
yeah that's what i said i was like we're
all gonna die that's great yeah and then
that's what i want you first
good night kids yeah yeah yeah feel it
back
sleep well yeah uh here's my question
for you i know that you
um uh because we're in some in some
communication i know you have
two very young children is it five and
two four and two
four and two uh four and two and you had
just moved in with your beautiful wife
into a
new home when covid broke out
so you'd think that's a good time to
move into a new home
but then it's got to be a double-edged
sword yeah i mean it's just like
i think i think that's like a what if
what if your house was also a prison
you know what i mean i do know what you
mean right
no and i have to say i live in a very
lovely home but i've had the same
feeling
of i've got to get out of here cut to my
beautiful wife
my beautiful kids nice home
all the food we need to eat what's the
problem
but that is just what happens when
you're told you need to stay inside
that's what yeah and that's what i mean
is like the hard part is like
the you know to like pay like for us it
was like this we were like
wow we're so lucky we're gonna get this
new home we paid for the home
and then we were there for two weeks and
then all of a sudden like it
we're locked in a cage with the four of
us just like
like locked inside our own
i'm revealing myself right now yeah yeah
it happened
it's clear that you thought it's clear
that you've gone to a very dark place
and it's clear that you're unhinged
dangerously unhinged my back
after a while i was like oh i'm never
gonna not look
tired i'm just gonna look tired for the
rest
first of all you've also got very young
kids my kids are teenagers right
um because i'm in my late 70s and you
are in this different wave of it i can't
imagine being quarantined with kids
that young kids that sometimes need
assisting assistants going to the
bathroom you know
yeah yeah that would be being in
quarantine with children that young i
would just say i'm going out for
cigarettes and not come back that's what
i would do
and i don't smoke people would know that
that's where they that would be they
would figure that out yeah
you'd be like i'm out for sick he's just
leaving he's just leaving candy
cigarettes
yeah it was it was hard i mean we grew a
lot uh
god bless my wife um she's
like without we if it wasn't for her
we'd truly
all be dead and i'm like dead serious
like we'd be dead um i'm sorry
i'm sorry you're just a you're a mental
wreck yeah
like like we're filming at here
and like there's cardboard cutouts and i
haven't seen you and god knows how long
um it feels really bizarre and strange
so
right um that's how that's that's how
like the oscar stuff has felt that's how
life has felt
yeah um but we pretend really good
yeah good yeah just pretend it's all
collectively pretend really good
this is what i'm curious about you are
now oscar nominated
and very deservedly so because as i said
your performance is spectacular
um and the movie's brilliant
but i also know that your background is
in comedy and
and doing a lot of uh improvisation and
i've done
a lot of sort of comedy improvisation
with you and remotes and
and when we traveled together to korea
which was still one of my favorite
experiences and i'm curious
are you do you feel like that you
identify now as an
actor or is there a part of you that
also still identifies with the comedy
self
you know that the kind of self-loathing
media
um funny guy i mean i'm deeply insecure
um i'm very neurotic
um at times very cynical
which i'm pretty sure is like the three
things you need
to be in comedy right yeah you're
missing a fourth which is bad at sports
oh okay okay i'm actually okay see see
that ruins it because whenever i meet
someone who's really good at sports and
they're like yeah i'm thinking about
being a comedian i'm like
no they can't exist on the same gene
they just can't
you just reminded me i was in my uh we
had a in college we had a theater
softball game
and i do remember what you're talking
it's so funny to me now
uh i went up to bat and everybody was
just having like a mediocre softball
theater time you know what i mean just
like
playing a version of softball right and
i got up there
and i whaled a homer yeah and
i now realize that like they were kind
of like groans
you know what i mean you're like oh
you're not supposed to do that here
yeah like it's not supposed to go that
far yeah
we're theater people that's what i think
about i just like and then i like
trotted the bases like an [ __ ] so